i just want to thank machine gun again
for also being a man who reveals his
feelings
and a gentleman um who is putting
something so fantastic out in the world
he's such a trendsetter and changing you
know what men do with their fashion and
flair and expression so his lacquer
company undone lacquer
as we heard about you know because he's
looking to
have a name that is less than perfect we
are all undone it's very sexy too um and
this is just incredible this product i
applaud him for putting it out into the
world he has a giant platform people are
following what he does
it's exciting when people take this
artistic license and do things that
include everybody and i'm so excited to
make sure to promote this fantastic new
brand that he has put out into the world
as we got into much
and many discussions
at the core also of what we wanted to
present to everybody is this wonderful
company that he started and i'm just so
excited for this launch he's such a
trendsetter
and just you know
gives the license for us all to play and
i just could not applaud this launch
more so get your undone lacquer
and play
[Music]
you